It's been an eventful week for me. Uh,
I've been telling people that I have the number one song in the world,
which is crazy. It's my, really my first, uh, my first, uh,
kind of stab at making, making real music.
Uh, no. Yeah.
I know a lot of you guys are probably wondering me about wanting him to talk
about the Eminem logic song that I should say logic,
Eminem song is logic feature and Eminem, but yeah, man, I,
they called me, uh, a week ago before, before the, uh,
like maybe a five days before the song came out and my manager was like,
look, the, you know, the remember logic. And I was like, yeah.
And he was like on an M and M and him are doing a song
and you know, they're gonna, mm.
Put your S your impression of him. Okay.
And the, and the song. And it looks like great sound.
Like he wants to know if they can use it. And I was like,
are you kidding me? And he was like, yeah, well, I'm going to say yes, but like,
I, I'm going to protect you as a cam.
Okay. And like, I was trying to get you money, by the way.
I don't know how much it's going to be, but, and I was like, dude, no,
don't ask for money. Just give it to him. I don't care. I'm not a rapper.
Let them use it on the song. It's comedy fine. So, uh,
you know, and then,
and then I put it and then I put it up and then they put it on a came out and
it's just like, I'll tell you one thing, man, look,
you do all these things as a comedian or I, you know,
whatever industry you're in, you know, as an actor, as a comedian, as a,
in the entertainment world, whatever the you want to say, like
all this stuff, you reach your, you know, you reach goals as they go on.
And you know, I've been wanting to do specials. I do specials, bam. You know,
my first specialist came out. That was, uh, uh, a Mark in my career.
That was like, amazing for me. Uh, you don't,
those are the things that even though they're goals, you exp you, you,
you expect them in a way because you,
you have confidence about yourself and your career. You're like,
I'm gonna do a special one day. It happens. You're like, wow,
I can't believe I'm doing this. But you also, you knew that this was the goal.
This kind of stuff is always like really special because you don't know that
it's going to happen. You know, you always thought, Oh, cool,
I'm a comedian. But when this happens, it's like, Holy.
I've been a big M and M fan for a long time.
I've been listening to a lot to logic for quite some time now to, before that.
Uh, and, uh, but I mean an em, an episode for like 20 years. So when he,
when he posted the tweet, when he tweeted about me,
that was really cool. He tweeted about my impression,
but then when he put it at the end of the, it's just kind of crazy to me, man.
Like, uh, it's just so weird.
It's a trip. It's cool. It's awesome. Uh,
and that's all I really have to say about it because you know,
I, you know, to, to even, I know you guys want me to talk about it.
This is why I'm talking about it, but it's very cool. Partying wants to play it.
Cool. And be like, yeah, you know, it's like rolling. This is together,
but it's like, it's, it's, you know, it's very cool. Uh,
and it's, it's cool to see, like, I mean, this is worldwide.
Like people from Germany are like, I just found out who this comedian is,
uh, that Dawson impression of Eminem, right? Uh,
here's an American comedian. There was this other guy that was doing a, a,
um, reaction video. I don't get reaction videos on,
I guess it's just like a, a thing on YouTube, but they're like, there,
there was one guy that was like reacting off of my video
or off of my impressions on M and M impressions. And it was so funny, dude,
the guy was just like, he kept on being like, all right, man,
he's onto something, man. He's onto something. M and M he's on C.
I saying that to Eminem rom that don't rhyme.
Um, there's reaction videos.
The song now has 11 million views on, uh,
on the, uh, what do you call it? A YouTube.
And then I posted way too many napkins as a comment. And it has 9,000
likes. And then I look at it all, but you know what?
The dorkiest is reading. That's the guy I'm going to play a little bit of that.
Reading the, reading,
the comments on the li the
YouTube, the song, the YouTube. Oh my God, dude.
Oh.
My God.
Maybe I know what it's like now for people who come across babies that are like
doing my language and. And people are like, what the are these lunatics doing?
Which I appreciate. I love. Cause you're gonna help us build the log cabin. Um,
uh, look it, look it, I'm just gonna read some of these,
this is just so funny to me. Police questions.
Me cops. How can you identify M and M me?
He doesn't breathe. It's all about
M and M and logic drops, homicide, entire mumble,
rap community as. Here we go again. Look at this.
These guys aren't humans, no oxygen needed. Just throwing fire.
Look at this logic wraps fast, M and M hold my oxygen,
dude. So dorky,
but love him.
Uh, Oh my God. People cutting down. Trees was never really the problem.
It was logic and M and M wrapping together. Ah,
cause they'd take all the odd. Here we go.
Arianna Grundy seven rings,
logic and M and M seven lungs.
Half-assed it. Plot twist.
M and M is logic's father. Oh, what plot?
Twist on a song like it's game of Thrones.
Wow. Um, I hear what you mean. Is there another one?
Logic Eminem? We have broke the internet mumble rappers. What? It cost logic.
M and M oxygen. Wow
dude. Oh man.
That's so funny. This guy, what's the, what's the guy. What's this video here.
W what is the guy? Uh, re re uh,
reacting. I guess this guy's pretty popular.
Um, here or this guy. It's a little penis and mean at the beginning of this guy.
No, like Shaq, his name is, so this guy is just.
Let's check this out. Y'all know. We, we,
we react to comedy a little bit on this, telling them so this'll fit right in.
And, and it's very relevant to what's going on. Okay. Brian Mills.
So we finna check this out.
I actually wanted to see him do the impersonations. Like,
I don't want to hear the audio. I wouldn't see him doing it, this kid.
And he started out for him and they were wrapper. Of course.
[Inaudible].
Oh, that's exactly how I am in nail raps, bro.
He had to start off with something,
go away now feel you don't forget what he started with. Now.
He'll come back instead of playing around with,
when he started with as exactly that and when they were wrapped, bro,
he bears and foes words that make it fit in his mind, screen broke.
And that's exactly what he was doing. I'm doing it.
And then he's just telling people I'm doing it.
And this has a hundred thousand views. This guy, this guy,
this guy kind of kills it. Huh? This guy kills it. This guy's,
he's kind of he's watchable though, for sure. Um,
anyway, that's been my world for the week. Um,
it's been very cool. Uh,
it's just cool when people kind of appreciate what you do. You know what I mean?